[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Mr.President, as faculty marshal, I have the honor to declare the 120th commencement of
Carnegie Mellon University, as authorized
by the trustees, to be in session.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]
>> Please rise for
the singing of our national anthem by
the vocal performance class of 2017.
>> [MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Good morning.
We are gathered in a wonderful place of
collaborative study, work and living.
Please be seated.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Together, all of us, we are diverse in our
fields of study, our talents and
our abilities, our ethnicities and
the places that we call home.
In light of a respect for others,
and with an acknowledgement
of our differences,
I invite you to join me, if you are able,
in a moment of silence as we quiet
our hearts in prayer in a posture
of thankfulness for this day and
for the class of 2017.
Almighty God, we gather today to
celebrate the diligent work and
the dedication of the Carnegie
Mellon University class of 2017.
We pause for a moment to give thanks for
those who have helped these
students achieve this day.
For the parents, family,
friends, teachers,
and any others who have been their
providers of support throughout the years.
We choose this day to be grateful for
the vision and direction
of those who helped make Carnegie Mellon
the institution it is today.
We give thanks to the leadership and
the administration, who continue to carry
on the vision of having a transformative
impact on society through continual
innovation in education, research,
creativity, and entrepreneurship.
Continue to teach these students,
and us as well,
to look with compassion on others.
Take away any arrogance or
hatred that may impact our view of others.
Give us the grace and
ability to love our neighbors and
to seek justice and
peace in all areas of life.
Bless these students as they enter
the next stages of their lives and
seek to reach their full potential.
Be with them as they take steps into
the known and into the unknown.
May all that they do, and
the decisions that they make,
honor you and the tradition of
Carnegie Mellon University.
We send them forth to impact
society in transformative ways,
through their work, through their lives,
and their partnerships.
Be with us this day and
let these students bring You glory.
Our heart is in the work.
Amen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Good morning, everyone!
>> It's a good day for the graduates.
Whoo!
On behalf of the Board of Trustees,
Let me welcome you to the 120th
Commencement of
Carnegie Mellon University.
My name is Jim Rohr, and
it's my honor and pleasure to serve as
the Board Chairman for
the 2017 Carnegie Mellon Commencement.
To all the students who
are graduating today,
let me begin by congratulating
you on your achievement.
This degree represents years of
hard work and self discipline,
of discovery and
creativity and problem solving.
I hope it has a little
fun included as well.
At Carnegie Mellon, a degree is
a sign that you have surpassed a high
standard of accomplishment in science,
art, and ideas.
And that you are ready to use
this knowledge in your lives and
your future professions.
You are ready to take on the charge
of continuing the long standing tradition
of doing the work that matters.
Congratulations to you all.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I would also like to wish congratulations to the family members, and to the friends, mentors, faculty,
and staff who also take great pride in
what the graduates have accomplished.
Graduation from a demanding academic
institution like Carnegie Mellon
is a team effort.
These students couldn't
have done it without you.
So I invite all of us to thank the support
team with a wonderful round of applause
for the supporters.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Now with us today at our 120th
Commencement are some faculty and
students from Carnegie Mellon's
other locations around the world.
I am particularly pleased to welcome
students from the CMU Silicon Valley
campus, and all the way from
Rwanda in our CMU Africa program.
And also our first to Lakshmi Subramanian
CMU's Africa Student
Excellence Award Scholars.
We are delighted to have
you here with us today.
As members of
the Carnegie Mellon community,
you are ambassadors of our distinguished,
distinctive university.
It was at Carnegie Mellon that you gained
solid grounding in your major field.
And it was at Carnegie Mellon that you
collaborated with people whose backgrounds
were very different from your own.
And it was at Carnegie Mellon that you
discovered new ideas about the world,
and, actually,
new aspects about yourselves.
As trustees, it's our job to uphold
the university's values, and
help CMU achieve further excellence
in fulfillment of those values.
Many trustees are here on
the platform this morning, and
I would like them to stand and
be recognized.
Trustees?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> This year, Carnegie Mellon has added to
its impressive momentum with
a number of new initiatives and
partnerships that are contributing to
the growth of knowledge in the world.
And we're moving forward rapidly with
distinctive and collaborative education,
ambitious research programs in areas
ranging from energy, data science,
workings of the brain, and
even the science of learning.
The campus footprint is growing,
with plans fully underway for
spectacular new spaces designed
to make CMU a standard setter for
the 21st century higher education.
With emphasis on collaboration
fields across the enterprise,
create problem solving,
as well as innovation.
But behind all of this growth and
expansion is our dynamic president,
who joined the university in 2013
from the National Science Foundation,
and who has already had a tremendous
effect on this institution.
It's my great privilege to
introduce the ninth president of
Carnegie Mellon University,
Dr. Subra Suresh.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Good morning.
>> Good morning everyone and
congratulations graduates.
I'm going to be saying that a few times.
Commencement is always a special day for
family, friends, and faculty.
But more than anything
else it is a milestone for
each of you, the graduates,
the class of 2017.
We are here to celebrate your
accomplishments over the past four years.
Or five years if you're from
the School of Architecture.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> You worked hard to get here,
and we are very proud and
honored to salute you today.
Let me also express my
deep appreciation for
the Carnegie Mellon University Board
of Trustees, and
to the Chairman of the Board,
Jim Rohr, for
all their energy, vision,
friendship and leadership.
With their help,
CMU is poised to have a bright future.
Thank you, Jim, and thank you, trustees.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I would like to also recognize a number
of alumni groups in attendance today.
The 2017 Distinguished Alumni Award
honorees,
the class of 1967 50th reunion celebrants.
And, of course, our legacy families.
Just to give you an idea,
yesterday morning when
we met with the 50th reunion class,
a number of things had changed.
A postage stamp was 5 cents in 1967,
today it's 49 cents, and
it says forever if you can believe it.
Carnegie Mellon's endowment at that time
was $75 million, it's much greater now.
There are many, many more things
that have happened since '67, but
the best news of all is that,
with every incoming class, the quality and
impact of Carnegie Mellon education
has increased substantially, and
you represent the very
best of Carnegie Mellon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
>> CMU is a beloved tradition in so
many families, and we are also
pleased to see successive generations
of family members attending CMU.
All CMU alumni here today
are specially designated by
the blue stoles they are wearing.
We are happy to see so
many of you back here.
Would all CMU alumni in attendance
please stand and be recognized?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It's wonderful to have you here, and
I hope our new graduates today
continue this tradition and
return to Commencement in the future.
One alumna who our new graduates
should get to know Is our
Alumni Association Board President Debbie
Yue, Dietrich College Class of 1989.
Debbie joined
the Alumni Association Board in 2010 and
began her term nearly a year ago.
While she was earning her Bachelor's
degree in Technical Writing at
Carnegie Mellon,
she was a reporter for the Tartan and
was active in the pre-law society.
Now a partner at the firm of
Gallagher Sharp in Cleveland, Ohio, Debbie
has been an active volunteer for the
Northeast Ohio Alumni Networks since 2007.
Having served previously
as network president.
She also volunteers as a Carnegie Mellon
admission interviewer and
is active in a number of professional and
community organizations.
And since taking office,
she's been an outstanding representative
of all Carnegie Mellon alumni.
I would like to invite Debbie
now to the podium, Debbie.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, President Suresh, and
congratulations to the Class of 2017 and
welcome to the Carnegie Mellon
alumni family.
As you begin the next
chapter of your lives,
please remember that you are now lifelong
members of the Carnegie Mellon community.
Therefore, wear your Carnegie Mellon
clothing, bring your CMU mugs to work and
be proud to be part of
such an amazing group.
Although Carnegie Mellon alums make up
only a small percentage of the world's
population, our contributions are great,
and our impact enormous.
We just celebrated the achievement in
service of a few of our dedicated and
talented alums at the alumni
awards ceremony on Friday
and I was inspired not only
by their achievement, but
by their incredible passion for Carnegie
Mellon, even 60 years after graduation.
No matter where your
life path will take you,
you will find Carnegie Mellon alums in
over 149 countries around the world.
We are leading communities, companies and
industries and
we are making the world a better place.
Although you are leaving the comforts
of your Carnegie Mellon home,
remember to always stay true to yourself,
continue to be intellectually curious and
continue to learn.
Be supportive of each other as well as for
those who are following in your footsteps.
And always go outside
of your comfort zone and
embrace your vision for the future.
The Carnegie Mellon Alumni Association
provides many ways for
you to continue to learn and to connect
with each other and with the university.
In addition to virtual programs,
we have over 55 active alumni
networks around the world.
Therefore, as you settle
into your new lives,
please find your local alumni network and
get involved.
And as with any family,
I wish that you will come back to visit
often, stay in touch, and think of us.
We wish you nothing but
the best and brightest future.
On behalf of the Carnegie Mellon
Alumni Association and Board,
it is my distinct pleasure to welcome you
into the Carnegie Mellon alumni family.
Congratulations, Class of 2017.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you very much, Debbie.
Our student speaker today, is one
of 129 students from 30 countries and
75 universities chosen this academic
year as a Schwarzman Scholar.
Today, Krystal Thomas earns her bachelor's
degree in biological sciences from
Carnegie Mellon University's
Mellon College of Science.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Krystal has been an active
member of the Carnegie Mellon community,
serving as founding president of Colors at
CMU, a student organization that promotes
open conversations on race and diversity.
She served as one of the inaugural members
of the Diversity and Inclusion Roundtable,
and is a mentor in the Coaching Minority
Progress and Success in Science program.
She's a past president of the Gates
Millennium Scholarship from the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation.
And is an Andrew Carnegie Society Scholar,
a distinction bestowed upon
only 40 graduating seniors.
The daughter of a Haitian immigrant,
Crystal plans to complete a Master of
Global Affairs with a concentration in
public policy at Shanghai University
in Beijing, China and
work to address barriers to healthcare
faced by immigrant families.
It was a great pleasure for
me this morning to meet Crystal's parents.
Crystal, I would like to now
invite you to the podium.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hi everyone.
Five years ago,
I came to CMU as a high school student.
I was here for the university's
Summer Academy of Math and
Science or SAMS for short.
Now, I didn't know that Carnegie Mellon,
or that SAMS,
excuse me, was a program for
minority students.
And the entire time, I was surrounded
by people who look like me.
So I left thinking, this is great.
Carnegie Mellon University, a historically
black college for math and science, right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm totally going here.
[LAUGH] Even though CMU wasn't
exactly what I expected,
I'm still so glad I decided to come here.
I have learned so
much while here at Carnegie Melon,
and not just academically.
Problem solving,
how to hold difficult conversations,
and most importantly, I now know there's
still so much more that I don't know.
What drives people?
How do our environments influence us?
How is our world interconnected?
I've started to think
about these questions,
because I've been fortunate
enough to meet many of you.
And getting to know your stories,
your perspectives and
the way you think about things,
I've been blown away.
As someone who came from a town where high
school students thought they couldn't go
to college if they didn't have the money.
As someone whose pediatrician told her,
at least one of us made it
out of this worthless place.
As someone whose relative told her,
isn't Carnegie Mellon a bit
too advanced for you?
I am immensely proud to
be a part of this campus.
And I am so
proud to be able to walk with you today.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> But what now?
We're about to leave the CMU bubble.
Some of us may start working and
receive nice paychecks.
Some of us may go onto graduate school,
and receive all right paychecks.
[LAUGH] And
some of us may take a well-deserved break.
But what, then?
Instead of thinking about the next
achievement, now's our opportunity
to reflect on purpose as we enter
the next stage of our life.
Purpose, the reason we exist.
Maybe Carnegie Mellon has already
helped you find your purpose.
Maybe you're just getting started.
We should reflect on purpose
because it develops us,
keeps us resilient and
can lead us to happiness.
So how do we crystallize purpose, or
even find purpose in the first place?
We help others.
We are driven by the need
to impact others.
We're social animals, after all.
I'm a biology major, trust me.
So what's the relationship between
purpose, helping others and happiness?
Well, to me,
there are three levels of happiness.
First, you can get happiness
from simply building something.
Then there's a second level of happiness
when people praise what you have built.
And then there's this
third level of happiness,
when someone tells you what you
have built has changed my life.
That level of happiness
just can't be beat.
And the path that makes you feel
the most fulfilled, the path that
gives you the greatest happiness,
can give you insight on purpose.
We've already been practicing,
impacting the lives of others.
We've overloaded, become execs on boards,
volunteered for 1000plus, tutored,
TAed, researched,
strived because CMU is a striving place.
We're a bunch of overachievers who've been
presented with so many opportunities,
and have been encouraged to learn.
Now's our time to put
practice into action.
Continue to strive.
Continue to aspire.
And as you leave here today,
center your life around purpose.
Center your life around impacting others.
Let purpose guide you.
And to everyone who
helped us along the way,
mentors who guided us
throughout the process,
faculty members who helped to
see just what we could do, and
loved ones who have been with us and
encouraged us every step of the way.
Thank you.
And thank you, class of 2017.
I know you'll do great things, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, Kristal.
>> Now we come to the presentation of
special doctor's degrees awarded to honor
individuals who have had extraordinary
impact in areas that reflect
Carnegie Mellon's trends in the arts,
sciences,
scholarship, and society.
Recipients of these honorary
degrees have in common
a notable record of achievement
in their chosen fields.
And they each have made in their own
domains substantial contributions to
the advancement of knowledge,
the enrichment of the arts and
culture, and
to bettering the well-being of humanity.
Provost Farnam Jahanian will
present each candidate and
cite the achievements
that merit this honor.
Then all candidates will together receive
their degrees and their doctoral hoods.
Farnam.
>> Good morning, class of 2017.
>> Good morning.
[APPLAUSE]
>> No, no, you don't understand.
This is a celebration.
We're gonna try this again.
Good morning, class of 2017.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Much better.
>> Let me add my warm
welcome to all of you and
extend my congratulations
to the class of 2017.
Will Mahzarin Banaji please come forward?
Mahzarin Banaji, you are one of the most
profound experimental psychologists
in the world, co-author of Blind Spot,
Hidden Biases of Good People.
You're highly celebrated for your study
of the disparity between conscious
expression of attitudes and beliefs, and
our less conspicuous implicit behavior.
You have been the recipient
of numerous accolades for
your work as a social scientist, professor
and senior adviser at Harvard University.
A fellow of the American Academy
of Arts and
Sciences, you'll receive
the 2017 American Psychological
Association's Distinguished
Scientific Contribution Award.
In 2016, you garnered the Association for
Psychological Science's William
James Fellow Award for a lifetime of
significant intellectual contribution
to the basic science of psychology.
And in 2015, you were elected
a fellow of British Academy.
Mahzarin Banaji, for your preeminent
contribution to psychology and
higher education,
Carnegie Mellon is proud to award you the
Honorary Doctor of Science and Technology.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will Vivian Davidson Hewitt
please come forward?
Vivian Davidson Hewitt, as a CMU alumna,
you have brought honor and
acclaim to this university throughout
your history-making career.
Shortly after earning your bachelor's
degree in 1944, yes, 1944.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> You became the first African American
librarian at Carnegie Library of
Pittsburgh, then went on to become
the first black president of
the Special Libraries Association, and the
first African-American chief librarian for
the Rockefeller Foundation,
the Carnegie Endowment for
International Peace, and
the Council on Foreign Relations.
An inductee of the Special Library
Association's Hall of Fame,
you were also sanctioned a dame
by Queen Elizabeth II for
your many years of dedication
to the order of St. John.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> While living in New York, your love for artistic expression led you and
your husband to start a collection
of Haitian and African-American art.
Today, the Hewitt Collection
is recognized as one of the finest
collections of its kind in the world.
Vivian Davidson Hewitt, for
your epic contributions to
library science and the arts,
Carnegie Mellon is honored to award to you
the honorary Doctor of Humane Letters.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will Michael Keaton Douglas
please come forward?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Michael Keaton Douglas,
your extraordinary acting talent has
brought you continuous critical and
public acclaim for decades.
Your outstanding leading performances
in two films, in 1988, Beetlejuice.
>> [APPLAUSE] [LAUGH]
>> You can cheer.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And Clean and Sober earned you two
Best Academy Awards from
the National Society of Film Critics.
Your portrayal of the iconic super
hero in the blockbuster films,
Batman-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And Batman Returns-
>> Has been entertaining audiences for
generations.
And you have been honored for numerous
awards for your roles in Birdman and
Spotlight, both of which won
the Academy Award for Best Picture.
Your passionate mentorship to students
as a visiting scholar in
CMU's Entertainment Technology Center
is helping to shape the future
of entertainment industry.
Michael Keaton Douglas, for
your extraordinary commitment and
contribution to the entertainment
industry, Carnegie Mellon is
pleased to award you the honorary
degree of the Doctor of Fine Arts.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will Bernard Osher please come forward?
>> Bernard Osher,
you have worked tirelessly since
1977 to improve quality of
life through your support of
higher education and the arts.
Your generous philanthropy over many
of those years has affected countless
organizations.
Your business acumen,
rooted in your family's hardware and
plumbing supply store, led you to become
a founding director of the second largest
saving institutions in the United States.
A renowned art collector,
you purchased the auction house
of Butterfield & Butterfield, and
oversaw its growth to become the fourth
largest auction house in the world.
Your support of
Osher Lifelong Learning Institutes,
including ours here at Carnegie Mellon
University, which is by the way
celebrating its 25th year anniversary,
allows older adults to extend their
education on university and
college campuses all around the country.
Bernard Osher, for
your unwavering service and
commitment to education and the arts,
Carnegie Mellon is honored to
award you the honorary degree
of Doctor of Fine Arts.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will Meg Whitman please come forward?.
>> Meg Whitman,
your exceptional leadership,
knowledge, and business acumen
place you among the most respected and
powerful women in the world today.
Your stellar record of
achievement is well-documented.
At Hewlett Packard Company, you led
an historic resurgence by creating two
Fortune 100 technology firms, Hewlett
Packard Enterprise, which you currently
lead as President and CEO, and HP Inc for
which you serve as Chairman of the Board.
You also have held executive roles with
Hasbro, FTD, and Walt Disney Company.
And your leadership at eBay led
to a truly remarkable expansion.
Under your direction, the e-commerce
company grew from 30 employees and
4 million in annual revenue to
more than 15,000 employees and
8 billion in annual revenue.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Your elite stature in the business
community serves as role model for
women In leadership positions in
every field, in every country.
Meg Whitman, for your distinguished
contributions to global business,
your superior leadership abilities and
your inspiration to future leaders across
the globe Carnegie Mellon is pleased
to award you the honorary degree
of Doctor of Business Practice.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mahzarin Banaji,
Vivian Davidson Hewitt,
Michael Keaton, Bernard Osher,
and Meg Whitman,
by virtue of the authority granted
to me by the Board of Trustees,
I hereby confer these
honorary degrees upon you
with all the rights, honors,
privileges and
responsibilities pertaining thereto.
Congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE]
Business leader, political activist,
philanthropist, these are all
descriptions of Meg Whitman,
one of the most successful business
executives in the world today.
Since 2011, she's been president, CEO
and/or chairman of Hewlett-Packard and
since 2015 she's been the CEO and
President of
Hewlett-Packard Enterprise and
chairman of HP Inc. Board of Directors.
As someone who knows her from
serving on that board at HP Inc.,
I can tell you, no one just shows up and
becomes president, CEO and
Chairman of one of the world's
most important corporations.
In a business world
overwhelmingly run by men,
Meg Whitman has earned every accolade,
and has repeatedly
demonstrated the benefit of pursuing
new and unexpected challenges.
Having been an accomplished
high school student athlete,
Meg set her sights on becoming
a physician when she enrolled at
Princeton just a few years after
women were first admitted.
But a summer spent selling magazine
advertising revealed her true calling.
This drove her to pursue her
Bachelor's degree in economics, and
then an MBA from Harvard.
Meg's path from there is meteoric.
She joined Procter & Gamble where
she worked with Steve Case,
who later founded AOL.
She took a position with Bain & Company,
where she rose to Senior Vice President.
And along the way worked with Mitt Romney,
who would later become Governor of
Massachusetts and compete for
the presidency of the United States.
Meg then served as
an executive with Disney,
Stride Rite, FTD, and Hasbro
before taking the helm of a fledgling
company that made her a household name.
AuctionWeb is probably not
the name you were expecting.
But under ten years of her leadership,
Meg Whitman grew AuctionWeb
into a multibillion dollar global
phenomenon, now known as eBay,
that has revolutionized
the way humanity trades goods.
Not content to rest on her laurels, Meg
started a charitable foundation that has
focused much of its giving on addressing
global warming and ecosystem restoration.
She's also dabbled in politics,
running an historic campaign for
governor of California in 2010.
In fact, The New York Times singled her
out as one of the women most likely
to become the first female
President of the United States.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Since 2011,
Meg has worked tirelessly at
Hewlett-Packard Company and
Hewlett-Packard Enterprise after
their historic split in 2015.
I give you the person Forbes Magazine
named the 20th Most Powerful Woman in
the World, Meg Whitman.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well,
President Suresh, members of the class
of 2017, members of the faculty,
distinguished guests,
fellow recipients of honorary degrees.
Families of the graduating class,
ladies and
gentleman, it's a true
honor to be with you today.
And it's a great privilege
to receive an honorary
Doctor of Business Practice degree.
And I am grateful to be earning
my degree in a lot less time and
with a lot fewer all-nighters than
it took many of you to earn yours.
To the parents of the graduating class
of 2017, it is a magnificent and
memorable day when your child
graduates from college.
It certainly is a wonderful day for you.
And I'm guessing that for
many of you parents,
it's a pretty good day for
your wallets as well.
Congratulations for having traveled
this journey with your children.
A journey that began not with their
enrollment at this university, but
at the moment of their birth.
Whether your children fully realized it or
not, whether they have fully expressed
it to you or not, and they will.
They would not be here today
without your love and support and
encouragement along the way.
So congratulations to the parents.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Most important to the class of 2017,
congratulations.
Graduating from college is
an impressive achievement, but
especially graduating from one of
the leading universities in the world,
an institution characterized by
high standards and excellence.
One that has produced
winners of Nobel Prizes, and
Turing, Tony, Emmy, and
Academy Award winners.
Carnegie Mellon University has
prepared you for a life of purpose and
meaning, and there are people and
moments you will never forget.
Including, I understand,
the Spring Carnival, which includes what
I gather are some pretty amazing amusement
park rides, booths, and buggy races.
To bag piping, which the school
has made into an art form,
and to my personal favorite,
the Band Without Pants.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> A tradition unique to Carnegie Mellon,
and I'm confident I can say one
you are unlikely to encounter
in your first full-time job.
You are graduating at a moment of
great challenge for our nation.
When our country will decide on matters
having to do not with just commerce,
but conscience.
Not just with what we will gain,
but what we will give.
Not just with our military power,
but with our deepest ideals.
This is hardly the most difficult
moment in American history.
I believe you can safely argue that
the Civil War, two World Wars,
and the Great Depression
have us beat by a long shot.
You are a blessed generation in so
many ways,
with opportunities unimaginable
to past generations.
And gratitude is one of
the hallmarks of a fulfilled life.
But every life has hardships,
every generation faces obstacles.
And we are in the midst of
a profoundly important moment
in the political and
civic life of America.
The challenges today are more
from within than without.
And I believe this is a moment that,
if we do not handle it well,
could produce harmful effects on
my generation and on yours, and
on generations yet unborn.
The stakes are that serious.
So today I wanna speak about some
disturbing trends in our national life.
Trends that need to be challenged
by people of both genders,
every class, race, and ethnic background.
Of every political party and ideology,
but most especially by young people.
Who are not only inheritors of the future,
but will do so much to shape it.
The first disturbing trend I want
to mention is the attack on truth.
There are many people these days,
including people at the highest level in
public life-
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Who use lies to devalue truth.
Those who are part of this effort
like describing what's happening
euphemistically using phrases
like alternative facts.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> But we know better to paraphrase
Shakespeare's Juliet,
a lie by any other name is still a lie.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> What is so
striking is the brazenness and
rapidity of the lies and their purpose
Which is to de-legitimize sources of
information hostile to those in power.
The lies tumble down like
rocks in an avalanche.
They are not subtle, they are overt,
obvious, and part of a conscious effort.
Language is being employed not to
reveal reality, but to obscure it,
not to simply mislead people but
to disorient them,
to assert power over truth in
an effort to deconstruct it.
So here's why this should matter to you.
If we do not share a common reality,
we can't reason together.
Truth creates restraints on power.
If we allow those with power to
control the very idea of truth itself,
then we cannot identify and
stand against injustice.
And if we can't identify injustice,
then we cannot replace it with
concepts like equality under law,
respect, decency, compassion,
and justice itself.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> A great university is always enlisted
against the spread of illusion, and on the
side of reality, said President Kennedy.
And that is the essence of your calling
as graduates of a great university.
My encouragement to you is to be women and
men who stand for truth.
Who spend your life in search of it,
even if you never fully know it.
Who believe in inquiries,
in facts, in objective reality.
And who have the courage to speak
truth to power even when there may be
a cost to doing so.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> If you do,
if you are defenders of truth in an age
marked by lies, it will have a liberating
effect on our fellow citizens and make
more possible all good things in life.
A second truth that needs to be
confronted is the attack on free speech.
>> In the last several years,-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> We have seen a powerful movement,
one that seeks to shut down free speech,
gain traction in the academy.
The very institutions that were
created in order to allow for
the free exchange of ideas.
On some campuses,
we've seen certain speakers not invited.
On others, they've been shouted down.
And on still others,
we are witnessing violence.
Now I understand this kind of thing isn't
happening on most American campuses, but
it's happening in too many places and
it needs to end.
But there's something
else going on as well.
College students are increasingly
demanding protection from words and
speech they find offensive.
We hear a lot about trigger warnings and
safe spaces which are designed to
protect students from viewpoints that
they might find upsetting and unsettling.
Here's why I think this is problematic.
For one thing, I don't think most of you
want to be treated like porcelain dolls.
And now that you are college graduates,
the rest of the world and
certainly the business world
won't treat you that way.
So no one is doing college students
any favors when they intellectually
isolate them.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> But
the issue extends beyond the walls of
the academy and matters whether or
not you ever step foot on a campus again.
While many of you are about to
complete your formal education, you will
spend a lifetime continuing to learn,
gathering and processing new information
and dealing with people with different
life experiences and points of view.
Shutting down free speech, insulating
ourselves from hearing competing points of
view is the equivalent of injecting poison
into the bloodstream of our republic.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> John Stewart Mill in his 1859 classic,
On Liberty,
put it as well as anyone ever has.
And I quote,
he who knows only his own side of the case
knows little of that, Mill wrote.
His reason may be good and
no one may have been able to refute that.
But if he is equally unable to refute
the reasons on the opposite side,
if he does not so much as know what
they are, he has no ground for
preferring either opinion.
Mill went on to say this, nor is it enough
that he should hear the opinions of
adversaries from his own teachers
presented as they state them and
accompanied by what they
offer as refutations.
He must be able to hear from
persons who actually believe them.
He must know them in their most
plausible and persuasive form.
So my encouragement to you is to be
the men and women who stand up for
free speech, who welcome debate.
Who model for
others what genuine dialogue is, and
who are not afraid to have
your beliefs challenged.
Too many of us live in intellectual silos,
where we seek out people and
information that simply
reinforces our existing opinions.
Venture out of those silos.
We are better when we are exposed
to different ideas and
competing philosophies.
Learn to listen in order to understand
others, not just to respond to them.
And remain open to
the possibility that you may have
something to learn from others.
Be the generation that
embodies real tolerance,
genuine inquiry and
authentic open mindedness.
It is what this nation desperately needs
during this fractured and fractious time.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The third
trend that needs to be confronted
is the attack on civility.
We live in an age of
escalating incivility.
We see it all around us,
on our roads, in airways,
in sports stadiums, and
on social media, and in politics.
The problem has gotten worse recently,
with those running for high public office
mocking reporters and demeaning
opponents with childish names or worse.
It seems that no words,
no matter how hurtful or cruel to
others are considered inappropriate.
We are fostering the conditions in which
we view others not as opponents, but enemies.
We're treating one another as subhuman and
that's a terribly,
dangerous line to cross.
Civility is more than nice manners, it's
a precondition of democratic dialogue,
in the words of Professor Steven L. Carter
of Yale Law School.
Civility is part of the, quote,
etiquette of democracy, unquote.
It allows for genuine social interaction.
It's been said that the true
genius of Martin Luther King Jr.
was not his ability to argue
the pain of an oppressed people, but
his ability to inspire those very people
to be loving and civil in their descent.
We should treat each other with civility,
not because we agree with others, but
because it is a measure of our respect for
human dignity.
It's what we owe all people,
including those with whom we
have fierce disagreements.
Our institutions, our culture,
our communities cannot be sustained let
alone thrive if civility is eroded.
It is an essential democratic virtue.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Kingman Brewster, a former president of Yale,
said, quote, the presumption of
innocence is not just a legal concept.
In commonplace terms,
it rests on the generosity of spirit
which assumes the best,
not the worst of a stranger.
My encouragement to you is to be
the women and men who embody civility,
who demonstrate a generosity of
spirit in an ungenerous time.
And who assume the best, not the worst,
of the stranger, of those you do not know,
people whose life experiences
are different than yours, and
who may see the world in a dramatically
different way than you do.
In doing so, you will make us
a more decent and just society.
This country desperately needs
the skills you have developed
during your years at Carnegie Mellon.
But it needs something more than
your skills, it needs your ideals.
You leave this great
university as better men and
women than when you arrived,
more knowledgeable and
better educated, I'm sure, but
I trust wiser and more hopeful.
There's a beautiful line by William
Wordsworth in his poem The Prelude,
in which he says, quote,
what we have loved others will love and
we will teach them how.
The faculty at CMU has taught
you what to know and love and
now it is your turn to teach others
what you have come to know and love.
I wish you all a life of joy and
purpose, of success and
fulfillment, and congratulations
to the great class of 2017.
Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Meg, thank you for
your thoughtful and sobering remarks.
We're not only inspired by your words but
also motivated by your example.
It's been an honor to have
you as our keynote speaker.
Thank you, again, Meg.
Please join me, once again,
in thanking Meg Whitman.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It is now my pleasure to
recognize the faculty members who have
recently accepted emeritus status.
Like all of our educators, these
distinguished individuals are scholars,
scientists, artists and
above all, teachers.
They have left an [LAUGH] indelible mark
on this university through the support and
encouragement they have
provided to our students and
through their legacy of
exceptional scholarship.
The names of all retiring faculty will be
projected on this screen at this time.
Those retiring faculty who
are present this morning,
please stand as I read your name.
Please hold your applause until
I have read all their names.
Mark Fichman, Associate Professor
of Organizational Behavior and
Theory, Tepper School of Business.
Peggy Anne Knapp, Professor of English,
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences.
Kenneth Kotovsky,
Professor of Psychology, Dietrich College
of Humanities and Social Sciences.
Gregory Lehane, Professor of Drama and
Music, College of Fine Arts.
Mel Siegal, Associate Research Professor,
School of Computer Science.
Please join me in thanking all of
Carnegie Mellon's emeriti faculty for
their service and
dedication to the university.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I would now like to recognize those faculty
members who were recently honored
with the title of university professor.
Being appointed a university professor
is one of the highest honors
that a faculty member can
receive at Carnegie Mellon.
Receiving this rank confers both honor and
obligation onto its recipients,
and denotes a legacy of exceptional
contribution to education,
artistic creativity and/or research.
This prestigious group includes faculty
from all of our colleges and schools.
I am pleased to announce that
three faculty members have joined
these distinguished ranks this year.
Nominated and recommended by academic
leaders and university professors,
and promoted to University Professor
by President Suresh and me.
As I read your name,
please stand and be recognized.
The first newly appointed
University Professor is Marty Gaynor,
E.J. Barone Professor of Economics and
Health Policy, Heinz College.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I'm also pleased
to congratulate Susan Tsu,
Professor of Design, College of Fine Arts.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The third
newly appointed University Professor
could not be here today, but
I would like to congratulate him,
Alan Frieze,
Professor of Mathematical Sciences,
Mellon College of Science.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> We will now begin the formal conferral of
degrees on all students who have duly
completed their requirements of their
programs to the satisfaction and
approval of their faculty members.
[CHEERS]
>> You can clap, it's okay.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The commencement
program gives each student's
degree an area of study,
which will be called out and celebrated
at departmental diploma ceremonies.
I encourage families and
friends to look and
listen beyond just your
own graduate's listing
to get a sense of the unique educational
environment at Carnegie Mellon.
The environment that makes this
institution so distinctive and
this graduating class so exceptional.
I wish to begin by acknowledging
the achievements of this year's
group of doctoral candidates.
These outstanding scholars received their
academic hoods at a special ceremony
yesterday afternoon.
In earning their doctorates, they have
made a commitment to a life of scholarly
pursuits, and have reaffirmed
the importance and prominence of
Carnegie Mellon as one of the nation's
premier research universities.
I would invite the doctor's candidates
to please rise and be recognized.
Doctor's candidates?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> There were about 300 of
them yesterday afternoon.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That party must have lasted really,
really late last night.
Please be seated.
There are some of them back there as well,
thank you.
In addition, we're pleased to
officially confer bachelor degrees
to students graduating from
Carnegie Mellon University, Qatar campus.
These students earned degrees from the
Dietrich College, the Mellon College of Science,
the School of Computer Science,
and the Tepper Business School.
At this time I want to recognize the Dean
of Carnegie Mellon University, at Qatar.
Dean Ilker Baybars, who has been
an exemplary leader of campus in Doha,
and who just completed his
last academic year as dean.
For the past six years, Ilker has led the
CMU Q campus with honor and distinction,
enhancing the CMU experience through
his passion for teaching and
collaboration and
his dedication to students.
Once a successor is named,
Ilker will resume his duties as
George Leland Bach Professor of Operations
Management in Tepper School of Business,
where he has been a member
of our faculty since 1978.
Dean Baybars, thank you for your service
and please stand to be recognized.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Candidates,
I'm gonna give you some
directions on what to do next.
Class of 2017, are you ready?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Okay, we'll try again.
Class of 2017, are you ready?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> We will ask each degree candidate from
each college, to stand and be recognized
as you're called upon by your dean.
When all schools and colleges have been
recognized, the President then asks all
students to stand again at which time
he will formally confer your degrees.
And don't be shy.
Last year, we had a bit of a competition
for the most boisterous school or college.
So let's hear your enthusiasm
as your dean calls on you.
That's an open invitation.
Are you with me?
>> Yes.
>>[APPLAUSE]
>> If not, just follow the person next to you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> For
the conferral of degrees at
the University level, when we call for
degree candidates to stand,
we will be calling for
broad categories of bachelors,
masters or doctoral level candidates.
I will now call on the dean of each school
or college to present its candidate.
President Suresh,
please join me at the podium.
>> We love you, Subra.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> To begin,
I wish to recognize James Garrett,
Dean of the College of Engineering.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> This is when the fun begins.
>> Making lots of noise,
will all the candidates from
the College of Engineering please rise.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mr. President, upon the recommendation
of our faculty I have the honor of
presenting the bachelors, masters, and
doctoral degree candidates from
the College of Engineering.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will the new College
of Engineering graduates please be
seated and be quiet, thank you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Dan Martin,
the Dean of the College of Fine Arts
could not be here today due to illness.
We wish him a speedy recovery.
To present the candidates from
the College of Fine Arts on Dan's behalf,
I now recognize Eric Anderson,
Associate Dean.
Eric?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Representing with even greater
enthusiasm, will all the candidates from
the College of Fine Arts, please rise.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mr President.
>> Upon the recommendation of our faculty, I have
the honor of representing the bachelors,
masters, and doctoral degree candidates
from the College of Fine Arts.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will the new College of Fine Arts
graduates please be seated?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I now recognize the Dean
of the Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences, Richard Scheines.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will all the candidates from
the Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences please show these
other students what enthusiasm
actually sounds like.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And do so as you rise.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Mr President, upon the recommendation
of our faculty, I have the honor
of presenting the Bachelor's,
Master's and Doctoral degree candidates,
from the Dietrich College of Humanities
and Social Sciences, [INAUDIBLE].
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Great job, now you can sit down.
>> I now recognize the Dean of
the Heinz College, Ramayya Krishnan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will all the candidates from
the Heinz College, please rise.
[APPLAUSE]
That's a good demonstration.  You need no prompting for me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Mr President.
Upon the recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the Master's and Doctoral degree
candidate from the Heinz College.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will the new Heinz College graduates,
please be seated.
>> I now call on the Dean of the School
of the Mellon College of Science,
Rebecca Doerge.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Dean...
>> as you know,
Dean Doerge has just completed her
first year as the Dean of MCS,
coming to us from Purdue University where
she led their statistics department.
We are delighted to congratulate her
on her first ever CMU commencement.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Alright, don't disappoint me.
Will the 2017 Mellon College of Science
[LAUGH] candidates, please rise.
And help Crystal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH]
[CHANTING] MCS. MCS....
>> Okay.
Mr. President, upon the recommendation
of our distinguished faculty.
I have the distinct honor of
presenting the Bachelor's,
Master's and doctoral degree candidates
from the Mellon College of Science.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will the new
Mellon College of Science graduates,
please be seated.
Congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I now call on the Dean of the school of
Computer Science, Andrew Moore.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Okay,
will this scarily awesome candidates
from the School of Computer Science,
please accomplish a decibel level of 06f.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
[CHANTING] SCS. SCS...
>> Mr. President,
upon the recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of
presenting the Bachelor's,
Master's and Doctoral degree candidates,
from the School of Computer Science.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Okay,
will the New School of Computer Science
graduates, please be seated.
>> I now call on the Dean
of the Tepper School
of Business, Robert Dammon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> You heard the challenge.
Will all the candidates from the small but
mighty Tepper School of Business,
please rise.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH] Thank you.
Mr. President.
Upon the recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the Bachelor's, Master's and
Doctoral degree candidates,
from the Tepper School of Business.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will
the new Tepper School of Graduates,
please be seated.
>> Carnegie Mellon, is proud to lead the
world in interdisciplinary research and
education, and
nurture several University-Wide,
Inter-College and Joint Degree Programs
within our university.
On behalf of all the Deans and
Program Directors
I will now present the candidates for
degrees from these special programs.
Will all of the Bachelor's, Master's,
and Doctoral candidates in our
interdisciplinary programs, please rise.
>>[APPLAUSE]
>> Mr President.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Upon the recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting these
candidates from our University-wide,
Inter-College and Joint Degree Programs.
I would ask these students
to remain standing
and I would like to invite
students from all other
colleges and
schools to stand once again, for
the official conferral
degrees by President Suresh.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> By virtue of the authority granted
to me by the Board of Trustees,
I hereby confer these degrees
upon these candidates,
with all the rights, honors, privileges
and responsibilities pertaining thereto.
I'm pleased to join the deans and
the faculty of the entire university,
in congratulating you.
Congratulations, class of 2017.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Will all the new Bachelor's,
Master's and Doctoral graduates
and the new Alumni Association
members of Carnegie Mellon University,
please be seated.
I'm immensely proud to stand before you,
the Carnegie Mellon University
graduating class of 2017.
In my charge to you, the graduates,
I wish to focus on two themes.
The number four, especially focusing
on the last four years of your
presence here, and
some thoughts and suggestions for
your career and
life beyond Carnegie Mellon University.
Four years,
that's an interesting interval of time.
Every four years we see a U.S.
Presidential Election,
Olympic Games, a soccer World Cup,
and of course a leap year.
Four years ago in the summer of 2013,
you arrived
on this campus as freshmen,
accompanied by your family members.
I had the enormous privilege and
honor of welcoming you to CMU
at the orientation event on the Mall.
I told you and
your parents at the time that like you,
I had just arrived on campus as
a freshman to begin the journey with you.
How many of you remember that?
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> In the succeeding four years
you have accomplished much in your
learning, your field of specialization,
in your personal growth, in your teamwork,
and in your global perspectives.
You have built valuable relationships with
your mentors and advisors, staff across
campus, faculty members, department heads,
deans, coaches, alumni, and trustees.
You've also contributed so
much to the fabric of this university and
its rich heritage.
As you walk the corridors of various
buildings, painted the Fence,
strolled the cart,
pushed the buggy at carnival, or
exhibited your enormous creativity and
technological prowess
in formal classroom work,
in theater, music and art.
In research and poetry, and
in presentations you produced and
exhibited on campus,
your determination to improve
the human condition and
your compassion and humanity came through
in the numerous community service
activities you initiated and
executed locally and around the world.
My wife, Mary, and
I were privileged to host many of you on
hundreds of occasions on campus and
at our residence for
conversations, entertainment,
meals, and social interactions.
And we came to see you not just as
students but as members of our family.
We celebrated major achievements together,
and we came together to hold and
support one another during times
of deep sorrow and tragedy.
While our faculty continued to
garner international recognition for
their research and creativity,
you, our graduates today,
have also accomplished
much in these four years.
Excelling in athletics,
creating artificial intelligence programs
that defeated four of the world's
best professional poker players
in a marathon 20-day poker competition.
Winning the Putnam Competition,
the premier mathematics competition for
undergraduate students in North America.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Competing
against the best undergraduate
math students in the country.
During your time here,
your accomplishments helped
the University scale new heights.
Thanks to the generosity of about 450
donors and the efforts of many members
of the CMU community the last four years
saw a historical buildup of dedicated
endowment to support students through
presidential fellowships and scholarships.
This program just established three
years ago has grown to benefit a total
of 255 students this year in every
college and school at Carnegie Mellon.
Similar efforts were created to support
faculty through endowed professorships.
Your ideas and
exuberant engagement helped the University
establish an historic expansion
of the campus to benefit
generations of students in teaching,
learning and research.
All this was fueled by one of the most
sustained and successful fundraising
efforts in a continuous four-year
period the university has witnessed.
This happened as the university's
visibility expanded around the world,
from pioneering university participation
at the Tony Awards on Broadway.
To faculty engagement at the World
Economic Forum in Davos, to hosting
the President of the United States on our
campus and to attracting several large
multi-national companies to Pittsburgh,
while at the same time we nurtured and
supported our activities at
CMU campuses around the world.
Your work at the university
community also brought to the fore
the critical need to enhance
the CMU experience for all.
This commitment has already produced
initiatives and action plans for
the next several years to improve programs
and infrastructure for counseling,
mentoring, and
enhancing student support and services.
We have accomplished all this together
in close partnerships with faculty and
staff, parents, families, friends,
coaches, trustees, and alumni.
Today we pause to reflect and
celebrate as well as recognize and
express our pride in what you have
accomplished in your four years.
And today, I challenge you again,
what will you do in the next four years?
As you go out into the world, in whatever
you do as a Carnegie Mellon graduate,
you have joined over
100,000 living alumni.
We know that you will be enormously
successful and impactful.
If history is any indication,
many of you will occupy leadership roles
where your principles and values will
determine the scale of your impact.
If you are a change agent, your world
will be changing even faster than
ever before because of the accelerating
pace of change around the world.
If you are someone who,
through hard work and aspiration,
tirelessly seeks to improve status quo,
it is imperative
that you adhere to your principles
even in the face of obstacles,
adversity and setbacks,
especially created by those
who are uncomfortable with the disruptions
that emerge from changing the status quo.
Rosalynn Carter once said, a leader
takes people where they want to go.
A great leader takes people
where they ought to go
even if they do not want to go there.
Such leaders make great personal
sacrifices to move their organizations or
their countries to a much higher level,
against incredible odds and opposition.
You may make some mistakes along
the way but you will learn from it,
and be a better person,
and a better leader.
Never be hesitant to voice your opinion.
Sir Winston Churchill once famously said,
when the eagles are silent,
the parrots begin to jabber.  Be an eagle, not a parrot.
Consider the case of Abraham Lincoln,
who many historians consider the greatest
president of the Untied States.
Lincoln, who led our country in
the middle of the Civil War,
established the Morrill Land Grant Act
in 1862,
that completely transformed the higher
education system of the US.
His signing of
the Emancipation Proclamation,
during a bloody Civil War that tore
the country apart, on January 1,
1863, as a Presidential Executive Order,
changed our society forever.
Also in 1863, Lincoln established
the National Academy of Sciences,
with a remarkable vision that
was free of political influence.
Lincoln faced resistance during
his entire leadership tenure.
Another iconic leader of
our times penned a speech
that captures this theme because
of the way it played out.
As I read this quote, try to guess to whom
it is attributed, the quote goes like this.
There will always be dissident
voices expressing opposition without
alternatives, finding fault but
never favor.
Perceiving gloom on every side and
seeking influence without responsibility.
That was a speech that
President John F Kennedy was supposed to
deliver in Dallas on November 22, 1963.
These words were in his
prepared remarks and
he never had a chance
to deliver his speech.
My charge to you is do the right
thing based on principles,
values, hard work, honesty, and integrity.
As graduates entering a new world,
facing new challenges,
it is your duty to ensure that fake
news does not overwhelm truth.
Noise does not drown out the signal and
mere superficial style does
not replace deep substance.
With a CMU degree, you are well
prepared to separate signal from noise,
fact from fiction, and
evidence from a mere innuendo.
As you accomplish much,
we expect you to return to this campus
sharing your knowledge and experiences.
Whatever you do, wherever you live,
you will have a profound impact on
the world equipped with a CMU degree.
I cannot wait to see how you change
the world, you were my freshman class and
therefore, you are my special class of
students forever, with whom I have bonded.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> With whom I have bonded so
much over the past four years,
I will always be connected with you,
congratulations, class of 2017.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> We will conclude today's ceremony by
singing the alma mater by the vocal
performance class of 2017.
We invite you to please rise and
sing along, the words to our alma
mater can be found in your program.
Also, please remain standing at
the conclusion of the alma mater for
the recession.
[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE]